salaam alaikum y'all ladies and
gentlemen
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims
very important stuff today
harami i don't know what's on your minds
what's on my mind right now
is uh you know that kevin samuels dude
in the red pill
sphere the manuscript thing
what days does he uh go live
not sure
because um
and just like him we should have a day
but we go live as well
you mean like a schedule yeah like a
schedule he's like everyone like that
this is the tv and this is when they're
going live and no one can go live
no other channel will like legally be
able to go live all the time
that's what i'm thinking about all right
bro let's get back after the intro
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too like we're more
willing to stick through with things
that we set out with an intention it's
impossible to have empathy for others if
you're not patient so my love bless you
for that first of all i agree with the
fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
but that was way too long all right all
right before we go in bro i had a
question bro is the skin in our private
area actually that sensitive to the
point where it creases up
very sensitive it's very relaxing
all right all right so it's been a
really uh honestly rather nasty week bro
we got superman coming at us bye
we got
batman coming out as try
no i'm kidding bro batman didn't come
out let's try there's this whole thing
of the woman uh tearing down the ads by
the way guys yes this is live like don't
don't think that you know it's like it's
friday right now 10 39 a.m eastern time
this is not like some pre-recorded
lecture become a member uh thing is
pinned on the live chat to uh
participate in the live chat
salaamwalekum
welcome to the culture
so um
shout out to that for the first uh first
comment okay aside from that uh
it's it's been a really weird week bro
like i want to be honest with you like
these things happening in the media in
the news it's not something like new you
know what i mean
and when you look at you know
just the way muslims are portrayed just
the way society is moving today it's
definitely something that needs to be
talked about
so
with that being said bro
there was a phase of my life where
before getting into this where i would
watch netflix so i would watch movies or
hollywood
and it would kind of be like just
operating on the
i guess the programming so you see these
types of things and it does you don't
really bat an eye you know they don't
really stick out you don't you don't
question things much
but now it's almost like there's things
where it's almost they're so normalized
people don't question it but i notice
these things i'm sure you guys noticed
some of these things too
you know what i mean so what do you got
to say about that
uh to be completely honest it's like
it's it's almost what to you know what's
to be expected from this kind of society
they have a very specific agenda they
have a very specific thing that they
want to push onto people
and every tv shows like oh we want to
represent you know everyone and by
everyone they just mean the people you
know that society cares about which is
lgbtq
predominantly i would say because now
there's some form of lgbtq in like every
single show and sometimes you know
multiple representations of it uh but
when they represent a muslim
it's always a muslim woman who is like
oppressed and ends up taking up uh
taking her hijab off and i know that
said a lot but it's because that's the
truth that is the cliche there's even
one show where it was like a female like
um police officer or something
and um
she falls you guys know those corn
uh
what's it called those giant like things
that farms with like like seeds or corn
or something like that um
yeah
where like she fell she had her jab on
she fell from the top through to the
bottom and she came out with her hijab
off and there was supposed to be some
amazing moment for like the white guys
that jumped in like you know stopped at
the cameras from being able to take
pictures of her i'm like
the whole thing is like you're you're
making a show about how people are
stopping people from recording her and
it's like you're recording her you're
recording that and it's like
[Music]
what's the matter with you why not just
have a woman who wears a hijab who keeps
it on and there's no issue
why does every single woman have to take
it off or have it fall off in some way
or or how if someone takes it off have
them get the life kicked out of them
because that's what should happen in
real life
but that's not what's going to show
let's talk about it let's go right in
number one namely the predominant issue
that i've noticed
is the normalization of co-parenting or
dysfunctional households all right
let me know if you guys have uh noticed
this like every single show or movie
that you watch you see like a little
girl a little boy and they're spending
like
i don't know the day or today it's like
the time to spend at moms and then
tomorrow's at dad's
it's almost like you rarely see like a
functional complete household now it's
always like split between this
co-parenting thing and it's very
normalized to the point where like
people don't even question anymore like
they're painting divorce and just this
there's no stigma against divorce by the
way at least in islam like islam divorce
is permissible but that's not the point
the point is
statistically
most households if you look around
they're not incomplete most of your
friends growing up didn't come from
divorced families
but they're portraying it as it's like
occurring 95 that's that's literally the
narrative you know what i mean so did
you guys notice that
yeah and on top of that the kid is
usually some disrespectful brat like all
the time
like the the the the parents disagree
with them and the kids like i hate you
mom i hate you dad it's like how dare
you not let me date this guy that's like
11 years older than me
okay and and that's like some level of
programming too because the kid's going
to watch that and by the way with with
the whole lockdown and everything like
that kids aren't really spending time
outdoors so kids are gonna see that
movie and they're gonna be like oh look
at the way that kids acting with their
parents therefore every kid must be
acting like that with their parents
therefore why am i being polite why am i
not cussing why am i being respectful
why am i not being noisy and unruly so
it kind of goes to show where a lot of
these
diffusion of responsibility situations
are coming from
yeah we're a product of our environment
we're probably what we see it's like a
monkey c monkey c type thing and i
remember i'll never forget this right
when i went to
get my motorcycle license
there's one dude
he was an older man it was probably like
in his 40s or 50s
and then he looked at me he's like
you got presents
you got you got something about you
and he's like you look like a leader
i was like oh thanks he's like but
in order to be a great leader you have
to be a great follower
and i didn't understand it in the moment
but then like when i thought about i was
like damn like we come into this world
and like all we're doing is just
observing everything
and we're following and that's
it's monkey see monkey do
so like if if someone thinks just for a
split second that like the tv shows that
are going on
the music that's in this
industry
uh our own actions our parents actions
friends teachers all this stuff if
someone thinks for a second that that
doesn't affect us that doesn't affect
the kids
[Music]
bro
before we go on with uh the observations
you want to go a little bit into that
bro what do you mean by
to become a great leader you must know
how to become a great follower
well in order to be a great leader you
first have to be a great follower
meaning that like let's say you want to
be a great fighter
in order to be a great fighter first you
have to observe other great fighters and
you have to
basically mimic what they're doing
otherwise you're just kind of like
trying to learn everything on your own
when it was already there
so it's again as monkey see monkey do
you have to follow and learn before you
can lead and teach
man
that's powerful bro
man there's another thing too bro like
if i'm being honest there's this
normalization of uh
adultery
fornication cheating it's like i was
watching the show subhanallah and
literally within the first sec first
couple seconds there was like a couple
just uh you know obviously doing what
they're doing
and
for the police don't worry i was
lowering my gaze
and then literally like two seconds in
it was like oh you have to leave like my
daughter's coming home you know what i
mean like
what like where did the whole thing
about a man and his wife
being together
like where did that go bro it's always
like just normalizing this adultery this
cheating and like kids are watching this
and they're growing up seeing and
they're gonna think oh okay that's
normal you know or if they are
considering cheating or something like
that they're gonna be like oh look it's
so normal everyone's doing it because
their whole
measuring stick of human behavior is
turning into netflix and the issue is
when netflix becomes the measuring stick
of human behavior and netflix being the
the king of fashion what do you think is
going to happen bro
of course they're just going to model
immorality and just this disgusting
behavior that's going on
bro and if you think if you think the
comic book stuff is getting bad like
just imagine netflix like
we we don't have people kind of like
actively speaking out right now but like
imagine what's going on in netflix right
now
that's like
it's just over our heads like we only
seen like the tip of the iceberg and
like the tip of the iceberg is already
bad as it is
hmm
i agree bro i agree harami bro what you
got to say
yeah it's found a lot it's very
unfortunate uh and if you look at you
know the tv shows of the past like go
back to the early 2000s or you know the
90s or the 80s or even back to like the
70s and before that you you'll see
there's a progression
you'll see there's a time where they
wouldn't really show much affection
on you know on camera there wouldn't be
much man-to-woman kind of stuff maybe
hand will be something like that you
know the basic stuff and then over time
it progressed and progressed and
progressed you know that guy um
came out with like the the playboy
mansion all of that they they actually
had like pornographic movie theaters at
a time
you know specifically for that and then
i moved on
uh from being in movies to magazines
to just being not exactly on standard tv
but more sexual on standard tv and then
after that homosexuality on standard tv
and just kept going and going and going
and now every single show there is
that's being produced has to have some
kind of sexual intimacy
whether it's straight gay trans this not
the other
and it's just progressing and now this
is the problem because
the very beginning was an issue with
promiscuity and and
this you know demonstration of intimacy
because this is not stuff that people
should be watching
because i'll say monkey see monkey do
and i don't know what came first the the
societal uh ideology and it's not
ideology but the societal
um practice or the the practice in the
tv show
right i don't know if society influenced
the tv or if tv influences society or if
it's you know a back and forth
relationship but as one got worse the
other got worse as well
there was a huge uptrend in and you know
women dressing down at the beach for
example and people being intimate uh
even in public
you may not protect us from that and
this is a disease man
really i don't i don't think it's either
you said was it the society that
affected the tv or was it the tv that
affected the society
i think it's it's something further than
that i think it's some like there's a
group of people who
have uh
ulterior motive they have the hidden
agenda
as to like what they're doing with tv
because think about it when tv first
came out
all it was was a pastime
it was a it was a way to enjoy yourself
with your family or your friends or
something and it was something that you
would do
like maybe once a week
twice a week or something like that but
other than that like you were out
you were out either if you were a kid
you were playing with your friends there
weren't no video games and i'm talking
about way before our time because we're
not even
young or we're not even old enough to be
living in this time that i'm talking
about but you had kids
who
were playing outside all the time and
then when they got older they were still
just being social
going out with people or
doing other things besides the tv the tv
was something like you know what
we don't have anything to do we have the
whole family here
let's do something all together as a
family and let's watch this little
program that they got going on but it's
like over the years if you look at how
the tv has developed how
it's it now has
way more than like five to ten channels
that's for sure and if you look at these
channels
primarily the biggest thing are
advertisements they're pushing out
advertisements and all these
advertisements work on a subconscious
level just like music works on a
subconscious level and then if you look
at the tv programs
like you see today netflix and all that
look at all the subconscious messages
that are being pushed out
and here's the problem here's where the
biggest problem lines is that
people who watch tv regularly
and i'll say this for myself because
when i used to watch tv regularly
it was a very like
unconscious
type act it's like it didn't take any
effort from me to turn on netflix
and just watch a series binge watch a
series right like you get so hooked on
the plot and like what's going on
whether it's anime whether it's some
kind of like random tv show or whatever
it is you get so hooked on it that it's
like
you
i would say your psychological barriers
begin to drop down and once your
psychological barriers drop down you are
now open to receive
whatever messages are being transmitted
through
the show and end of itself it's like
music when you listen to music long
enough
you get to a point where you submit to
the music and then it's like whatever
message that music is
is thrown at you you're taking that in
100
[Music]
yeah i just want to say guys we we got
uh
75 viewers and only 48 likes come on
what is up with that please like the
video really helps push the algorithm
but uh i hear what you're saying bro and
it's like i want to add something like
back then
there were only a finite limited amount
of channels too
there weren't 60 70 channels with you
know late night things that kids can
watch and there's none of that bro
there's literally like two or three
channels
and you're probably watching when there
are other people in the house
there's no internet the good old days
bro
bro and like the best days were
saturdays for me
i used to wake up saturday morning i
forgot what channel was
but like they used to throw on all the
shows like
um yu-gi-oh
and all this stuff bro
i don't know
but now it's changed now it's like it's
always there
is you guys you guys watching as a kid
oh yeah a little bit
i saw yu-gi-oh pokemon digimon
uh a whole bunch bro samurai jack y'all
remember samurai jack
was that
yeah but that one was legit
powerpuff girls
yeah i remember that sailor moon
dragon ball z
yo y'all remember that weird uh
i think it was bi or trans it was in a
powerpuff girls bro it was like that
lobster looking thing
yeah
that was weird bro even as a kid i knew
something was up with that
jojo
and then bro today like
that's like every character you know
what are you going to do
yeah
and um
again i know i say this a lot but i
really want to push this point that
everything that we're seeing in life is
just a product of the the basic
foundation of our you know society which
is capitalism secularism liberalism you
have we have a society of people who are
taught
uh they want us it's it's almost
instinctive because you know their
desires for us we want to do these
things
but on top of that we have society
that's teaching us to just let them go
they're not teaching us to restrain
ourselves right allah didn't just give
us our our nafs and our desires allah
gave us our
our intelligence and the knowledge and
wisdom to be able to be like yeah but i
probably shouldn't because i know it's
probably not good for me in the long run
right that's why there's you know so
many people who
um post themselves online that instant
gratification so are there so many men
that just watch women online because
that instinct gratification and that's
why they put these things in these shows
because they know that this is the state
of the people and they want to give the
people what they want but they don't
understand that they're feeding into
this
very destructive disease it is a cancer
that's overtaking society and this is
why we have more rapists
because men are just disgusting nowadays
because they're all perverted because of
what they watch they like to watch you
know very very
demeaning things to women and that's
what society is pushed that's why we
have many perverted men um
also why we have a lot of like you know
forgive me feeling the term about you
know cuckolds nowadays as well a lot of
people who like
and and so on and so forth
and this is a disney
no that's nice
it's something we're gonna come up with
merch soon with uh don't be dye youth
t-shirts
what does that use mean
the youth is a is a man who is not ryuba
meaning he lacks frida
so
so you know
all right i was gonna what i was gonna
say rami
salaam alaikum i mean
[Music]
what i was going to say for you bro what
you just said
i think the most important part
that people need to start doing is just
spending less time
um whether that be watching tv
whether that be on social media or just
on electronics in general
because it will develop more awareness
and then it's like
now when you do go on to social media
now when you do go and watch that that
tv show or
that uh anime
series that you want to watch it's like
now you have awareness and you can
actually kind of break down and see
what's going on
i knew it all true true
yeah but you can kind of see
you can go you can see what's going on
behind the scenes you know it's kind of
like
uh when we used to watch disney movies i
don't know if y'all watched movies in
the past but when i was a kid i watched
these movies like it was one thing but
then once i
started becoming aware of like all these
different ideologies and these different
like
uh
isms and and just things that are being
pushed and then i watched disney movies
again i was like
i didn't see that before
mm-hmm
it's also the only reason why all of us
now are psychologically way different
from before when people didn't have as
many mental obstacles as it is so common
now that is
facts that is very true
very true
yeah
so uh society is suffering from
depression
anxiety
mental illness
immense amount
let's talk about this test have you guys
seen the movie jamie on netflix a gay
boy kisses a muslim girl okay let's talk
about that so
the portrayal indeed
i want to say
dehumanization and degradation of muslim
uh men and women particularly sisters
this is something i've been noticing on
netflix and uh particularly the film
industry as a whole uh you have a woman
and the the said narrative goes as
follows she's a she's oppressed
she comes from a family that is
culturally oppressive and abusive
towards women right
uh on islamic completely because i don't
know where this issue came from where
this ideology came from that women are
to be less valued than men uh just
because they're women i don't know i
honestly don't know
i can't fathom like where this even came
from it's not from islam because if you
think about it islam literally came as
an antidote
to stop this uh
cultural i guess dissociation between
men and women and value
so okay
they they have this family just like
there's non-muslim kuffar families
putting men over women so i don't know
why they're equating this to islam but
cool
it's always some culturally either uh
you know pakistani or african family
from what i've noticed uh the the woman
is just like she's shunned she's
oppressed and she needs to be liberated
furthermore it's never gonna be in a
muslim country it's always gonna be like
this muslim woman is going to be in uh a
non-muslim land a kofaland
and she's surrounded by uh men and women
that are drinking
uh committing zinna
and and they're free quote-unquote and
she gets a taste of this this is usually
how the plot goes right because i'm
gonna just you know let uh the kofa do
the things and uh you know keep the
muslims pious
so then she's like she goes home she
wants to partake in this and there's now
this barrier right
and the way they portray this barrier
is it's very subtle they usually portray
the barrier uh i guess directly or
overtly
uh
explicitly as the family
you know what i mean it's like the
family is getting in the way from this
girl
uh from spreading her wings and being
liberated whatever that entails you guys
know what i mean
uh the subtle implicit underlying covert
message though is that the barrier is
islam but they're not going to just put
that right out there because that's too
much it's like it's way too obvious now
you know what i mean
um so essentially what they're saying is
islam is preventing this girl from being
free
therefore we need to come liberate this
oppressed woman so essentially then the
woman goes on her own self
i guess expressing
journey of spreading her wings and
flying and doing all this and she
finally gets to be free
now the take home message from that is
we the west we were right all along
y'all the
muslims y'all were backwards and twisted
and barbaric
so this is how it should be and a person
walking away from this tv show or movie
they're not gonna have a good taste in
their mouth about islam
what do they do they put movies like
cuties
a movie to normalize uh
pedophilia i like to say it but it is
what it is
little girls shaking their rears on
camera and wearing little skimpy outfits
and enough is enough this has gone too
far and what do you know as soon as i
hear that plot wallahi i didn't know
it's a muslim family
but i guessed it and as soon as it came
out it was a muslim family
you got another movie with uh a hijabi
ali dal made a video about this this is
this is outrageous you got a hijabi
breaking her fast with a shot of alcohol
and to top it off right before it
bismillah drinks it
i was watching a tv show called midnight
mass
and there's uh there's a sheriff
sheriff hassan the only muslim guy
of course
google it the actor is hindu he's not
even muslim
when he's praying he's not even
you know sitting properly
so it's just like
the representation of of real islam is
completely lacking of course
but the
misrepresentation of islam it's just
everywhere bro
yeah
you know it's it's funny that you
mentioned that like they're trying to
portray islam as a barrier because islam
is the barrier
and the netflix is one of the most
powerful weapons used to fight islamic
violence in islam it should be boycotted
by muslims that cost 100
100 percent and that's just that's just
one
one of the things that's just one of the
problems yeah yeah because as i was
saying
most community i plugged in getting
pretty much yeah yeah and that actually
ties into what i'm about to say about
netflix and everything the barrier is
islam and the problem is not them
showing that islam is a barrier that's
actually what we want we want people to
know islam is the barrier to immorality
but the point is that they have to
stress that on the other side of that
barrier is immorality and not freedom
it's not freedom liberation you think it
is when you're on the other side you're
going to be depressed you're going to be
anxious you're going to want to kill
yourself eventually you're gonna hate
the way you look you're gonna hate the
way you feel you're gonna hate who you
are and you're gonna want things that
are completely unachievable and you're
gonna end up hating your life you're
gonna be wanting to kill yourself that's
what's on the other side on the side of
islam
is is is beauty and contentment with
remembrance of allah it's the the
knowledge of jannah being able to go to
jannah being protected from the fire of
hell it's protection from immorality
it's protection from basically from
yourself harming yourself
because they even know how to protect
yourselves
i've noticed that with shows that
include us that include muslim women
there's always either a gay trans
character included
like they want to appear that they are
okay with muslims when really they are
not yeah
yeah
bro and
just to top it all off all right
this is how they act subtly i this this
is how they work they they try to
influence us
through
[Music]
freedom
because every human has this innate
feeling of wanting to be free because
that's that's how allah created us with
free will right with free
will
so freedom is a part of free will
because we have the choice now to make
whatever decision we're going to make
and we have to reap whatever consequence
is of the decision that we make now
because they've realized this ah each
human reacts to freedom
right
they say okay well we don't have to tell
them hey no we're not don't do this
we're just gonna suddenly slide it in
there where we plant this seed and then
the seed begins to grow in their head
and then they start thinking to
themselves
ah
islam is not present is not preventing
or islam is preventing me from being
free uh so-and-so is preventing me from
being free uh my parents that prevented
me from being free
they put all this stuff in there so
delete to where after a while like if
the person is not aware
they're going to basically adopt
those thoughts that were implanted there
and then they're going to take it as
their own and they're going to start
rebelling and doing all this stuff
when it's like yo it's
it was all fake to begin with
like you're most free when you're with
allah when you're with the creator when
you're in islam
and yeah i'm just
i don't wanna leave you there bro i'm
gonna
i was getting fired up that comment that
said get the likes up guys what are you
doing we got over a hundred viewers
mashallah it's been under half an hour
please get the likes that helps promote
the video
all right
what was that comment
uh oh the one when anna was uh going off
yeah
let's see
t3m do you brothers believe reformists
have a massive part to play alongside
these disgusting netflix hollywood movie
series yeah hundred percent um these
reformers like i and hiroshi ali like
the whole narrative is we escaped and
now
look this is this is what needs to be
done to
uh make islam more appropriate for
society but not freaking question why
society's so degenerate and should be
used uh by the standard of the measuring
stick of islam
yeah they're asking the wrong questions
bro to be honest
exactly
the user desires against us to doubt
anything that restricts this desire
the assumption is that desire is the
only principle that is valuable yes yeah
that that is literally
one of the the principles of of
capitalism that people should go for
what makes them feel good facts why do
you think there's a collective push to
be so progressive by
every media outlet okay uh very good
question test jazakallah so
my understanding of it um my limited
understanding of it uh my finite
understanding of it as uh just another
human being bro cause there is again i
can't claim to know the the end or be
all truth of how the system is working
but what i believe it is is
[Music]
there's a tremendous push i believe to
divide and conquer
this unity
the islam was sent for everyone islam
was incent for
you to be have uh achieving salvation if
you're ethnocentric
region-centric nothing like that islam
was for everyone
islam was truly meant to unify the the
ummah the human race now society the
jalik system all he's trying to do is
try to divide and conquer you got the
lgbt even in there you got the spectrum
you got liberal conservatives bro that's
all part of the same thing then when you
guys can open your eyes there's no like
us versus them
they got
yes too vaxxed and then you got
anti-vaxxed or you got yes to mask
anti-mass like everything has just us
and them and when you keep creating
these divisions in society what you're
gonna end up with is just
people that go with status quo
and people that go against status quo
and this has to do with hard-wired
biological mechanisms in us we used to
be part of tribes believe it or not
and when somebody believe it or not
doesn't fit the good or best interest of
the tribe they get kicked out of the
tribe
and we have this innate subconscious
mechanism in us that we do not want to
get kicked out of the tribe
because that breeds uncertainty
that breeds danger
and when that comes we're going to do
everything we can to stay a part of this
tribe meaning doesn't stay plugged into
the matrix stay a part of status quo
stuff like that we got a question for
anha very recurring question but uh i'm
depending on the less
i try to stand
all day if i can
it's actually best for us to stand all
day
we a lot created our bodies for movement
not to be sitting down and it's they
actually have studies on this
when you sit down for x amount of time
uh number one your blood flow
begins to become less and less
and with less blood flow
means
your body is burning less calories so
your metabolism slows down
and then if you have less blood flow
you're more prone to have more
inflammation
which
you know what inflammation does in the
body
so it's best i sit down i like to eat
and stuff and maybe like towards the end
of the night to chill out
um but standing up i like standing up
that's good
interesting uh
interesting name uh what is the topic of
today's talk it's uh it's in the title
lucky
before i read this guys if you guys are
on apple podcast or spotify what are you
doing get on youtube watch these because
uh
part of the experience of the t3m
journey is uh visual so you guys are
missing out on that your thoughts on
countering this liberal narrative by
using media movies series okay any of
you have an answer to that i think it's
possible
yeah i agree i think it's possible but
people have to be very careful because
in islam the means or the ends does not
justify the means right
we we talked recently about how when
someone does something the wrong way
with the right intention they get a sin
and when they do something the right way
with the wrong intention they get a sin
right you need a good you need good
action and good intention so if you're
putting like music in the movies
or you're showing people's aura in the
movies or you're showing anything that's
just you know haram that shouldn't be
there and by you know scholarly opinion
not my own by scholarly opinion then you
know you very well may be sinful
that's something we should avoid and
nowadays movies and tv shows they all
have a form of that so people might find
it difficult to watch a show that
doesn't have certain things like music
so then it's going to encourage you to
play music but then what are you doing
you know you're falling with the haram
so it's possible i think it's a good
idea you just have to be careful with
how you go about it
guys in every single stream i have to
address these two points one y'all gotta
stop asking the same
joke
and number two
about this man like come on we can't be
talking about this right now
on my right usa seems like a completely
different world bro
yeah
where you coming from with that like
where you live where you living more
because i know usa is different because
i've seen like
south america
and like how their culture is and
everything's over there but for the most
part like
we have things that are subtly being
pushed in every culture and every
country in this world
so
america is not that different if you
think about it
mm-hmm
hmm
i actually never watched it to be honest
okay let me give you a rapid-fire
question to both of you what is the most
cringiest misrepresentation of muslims
or just i guess just degeneracy you've
seen in uh anything in your life or
lately let me know
both of you
so many to pick from
someone you pick from i know
[Music]
i'll go first there was a there was a
movie called candyman have you heard
about it it's a new horror movie
uh
tldr there were two couples
all right two couples
in the movie two main couples
first
couple heterosexual heteronormative but
a man completely in his feminine frame
seen as uh
just a a simp
completely lost like he's a child that
never got love from his mom
and the wife who was
very dominant and assertive and
definitely leading in the interaction
which is weird so that was one couple
out of the two
and the other one was a gay couple
i thought you were gonna say there was
something like a muslim couple or
something no like literally bro the
the sub-communicated programming from
that is literally one in two couples are
gay i know like people won't see that
but that's literally what it is
and then the other one's basic
and the other one is basically
role reversed
whatever it is so
uh yeah i mean it's true bro like if you
talk to most dudes that are
i guess i i would say blueprint but we
could take that term out of here and we
could just say they are
they're still running off like uh old
programming they're not they haven't
like woken up yet
when they talk about their wives it's
like you ask them like yo like let's go
get something to eat or oh let's go work
out let's go training like oh let me
make sure with the misses first let me
know let me ask you mrs say ah you know
what if the wife is happy then i'm happy
come on bro
come on
yeah what are you doing
yes
you know it's it's almost like the thing
with the kid that i mentioned before
where the kids see the kids act up on tv
and then the kids in real life act up in
real life because of what they see on tv
it's kind of like it's pushing this
narrative that the woman is in charge as
far as saying
and
now all the women are gonna you know
want to be in charge but there is a
level of that
where it's like they have to assume a
role of authority because the men aren't
you know what i mean like it's a two-way
street
uh there are women that weren't really
raised with a proper father
so their mom was in charge
right or they didn't have a father and
then eventually they had to you know
try and be the authority so it is a
two-way street
but
my example would be now i used to watch
prison break right i used to love that
show
then they made a fifth season right
completely ruined it for me because they
went to some arabic country
and there's all this terrorism blah blah
blah garbage and you know how they're
going to portray that and the worst part
about it is there was a hijabi
that ended up like kissing one of the
guys and it's like
if that was bro that was a muslim her
family would like slaughter you
in the streets
they like kill you bro like
it's messed up
man who would ask why do you guys
think
is the best okay maybe you mean what do
you guys think is the best step forward
for young muslim men to protect his dean
knowledge
and understanding
seeking
i'd say awareness
yeah yeah i would i would put that with
within
because it's like knowledge of the
reality you know what i mean what's
going on
yeah did you guys interview hamza okay
cool quick uh okay thinker jazakallah
for asking that so uh
bro
what'd you say his name is the thinker
not the thinker girl
it's the thinker you said
thanks thinker
i your thinker listen up bro
uh pertaining to the question about
hamza i want to address one thing right
now um
angel made a point about a minute ago
about
saying that that couple was like the man
is operating it like he's thinking blue
pill like this whole term guys when we
use blue pill or red pill we are
speaking objectively about
being
woke versus not woke we're not talking
about the movement when we're talking
about blue pill it's like you're
literally programmed the way society
wants you to be as a man
that's all we're saying
and this leads me to hamza so hamza he
has a self-improvement channel mashallah
uh very
he's he was born muslim but it's it's a
very like
male oriented channel i'm sure he has
viewers that are women but it's like a
it's kind of like a self-improvement
channel a little bit of red pill stuff
and recently he's uh been in contact
with us he watches our podcast and he
realizes that there's more to life and
he's very interested in some so what
we're doing is at worst it's going to be
one episode at best it might be like a
mini series and we are basically going
to be documenting his journey to islam
and inshallah miguel that he gets guided
to it and he has a lot of questions so
we're going to be filming inshallah
tuesday
expect that it's out uh sometime
within a week after that
inshallah
we got that we got philosophy coming up
guys i'm giving away everything right
now come on now
we got faraz zahabi
we got dawg with kim
he messaged me this morning
uh it's just a matter of booking him in
now
we got uh
i wrote some other people down
inshallah good stuff coming up however
every single friday inshallah you will
see us
uh in the morning just as three usual
weekly episodes nonetheless
do you mean hamzah yeah
the best builder in my opinion is uh
jojoba things called jobo oil
it's only one ingredient
super cheap you can get like a huge
bottle that'll last you for like six
months maybe even a year if you use a
little bit at a time
bro it's i've found it to be the best
stuff because like not only can you put
on your beard but you can put on your
skin is the one oil
that
i want to say
is almost identical to the uh
i think it's called sebum
or just the oil that our skin produces
so it's not going to make your skin more
oily
nor is it going to uh dry your skin out
it's basically just going to like keep
it just right and then allow your hair
to
be at
the natural softness that it should
may allah bless your efforts we gotta
make a link up event in toronto asap
inshallah inshallah don't know how
anna's gonna get there but inshallah
hmm man he was
it was
good
okay sp rides definitely going to watch
for us as a hobby
joe rogan's never been the same after
frost went into his podcast
probably
yes you tell me the man was shook
yeah yeah yeah
i gotta have some philosophical
questions for the man bro cause y'all
saw all i have is like training related
questions yeah but then again like maybe
that might be good because like y'all
will have the physical or the uh psycho
uh the
last philosophical and i'll have the uh
training
question because i'm sure y'all didn't
really have much training questions
yeah i didn't
it balances itself out bro
find the piece man uh
five is always one in the lead romney is
the one who breaks uh i know the youtube
sensation bringing some show vibes
that's that's one way to look at it bro
definitely bro
food ass okay let's keep it real if
someone is
gay or bi and he wanna fix himself
what can he do
just come closer to allah
that's it
yeah
allah will hear you
allah will allow you
to get past these uh
perceived issues that you have inside
your mind
yeah
okay
uh this kind of relates to
netflix and hollywood but uh
how to solve a p addiction okay all
right let's talk about this so the first
thing i want to say is netflix and
hollywood i believe is a
precursor to why men have a pee
addiction today watching p
uh those of y'all on apple podcast or
spotify once again
what are you doing bro get on youtube
because you're probably like what is a p
addiction you know what a p addiction is
men and women
definitely i don't want anyone to think
of just a male issue today but
predominantly men right because women
are they'd rather read romance novels
than watch uh stuck following you you'd
be
you'd be surprised a lot of women
nowadays are actually watching i would
be surprised bro but they read romance
levels too men don't really read romance
novels unless
they're not in their frame uh how to
solve that okay so anyway my point was
netflix and hollywood to keep a long
story short to cut a long story short
they basically are over exposing
and objectifying women
kind of contrary to feminism which they
don't want to be objectified but cool
walking talking contradiction you go
outside women objectifying themselves
you look at ads and uh billboards
they're objectifying themselves and it
basically desensitizes your response to
women
what happens when a decent size is your
response to a woman
your wife's no longer gonna do it for
you your wife at home who's a regular
human being without editing and all this
extra abnormal makeup and all that and
post-production and all this if you guys
really know what goes into it
subhanallah she's not going to do it for
you anymore
so now
you need to go and find the next
dopamine hit
the next genre is this this is what
mahdi said
facts
this is literally it bro this is this is
why uh lowering your gaze
literally does make you masculine yeah
because it cuts off
this over stimulation and
desensitization it forces you to be okay
with less it's kind of like a dopamine
detox for your sexual health
yeah i think i think brother gabriel
spoke about this as well
um ramen do you have anything to add
before i go in
no man go for it all right so
hey go back bro go back you can try to
find the question
oh it basically asks why is p addiction
here today
i don't think i'm finding bro too many
comments
all right so um
basically getting past a porn addiction
is a very long process
and it's going to look different for
each person
but the first thing
is realizing
that the society you live in
is actually trying to pull you into the
addiction
everything around you is trying to pull
you into the addiction
and um
[Music]
it might not be
direct
sometimes it will be but for the most
part it's subtle
it might be like oh a car
uh advertisement
and they have the woman on there
and it's like well
now they're affecting your naps
they're affecting your sexual desires
or you are probably more prone to
actually purchase this car
or go to the dealership or whatever it
is think about it think about the
advertising because the girl was in
there
so
number one is realizing that the society
everything around you is pretty much set
up for you to fail
so that means that you have to really
set yourself apart from that and spend
less time
in
social media
in youtube in netflix and on all this
stuff but then when you go out into
public like fire said
in regards to what mahadee said is
yellow your gates
now obviously ahmed he got that from
the
allah told us to lower our gaze for very
clear reason
all right now
you start lowering your gaze
beautiful you start spending less time
on uh social media and all this stuff
beautiful that's one step of the
equation now the next step is the fact
that you're going to have desires you're
going to have wants to actually either
go and watch
this filth
or
to just
release
right because you you feel like you need
to release
and stuff like that and that's where you
need to change your lifestyle so you
can't take something out and then have
everything remain the same because what
ends up happening is you're going to
inevitably fall back into the same cycle
that you were in before so
let's say that uh your routine
is that you come home from work you eat
you're watching youtube videos then
you're chilling on your bed
and then from the youtube videos in the
past you would have gone and started
watching that fifth
and then from there maybe you would have
watched a little bit more videos maybe
we'll play video games or something like
that and then you're gonna see
if you take away
the pornography you take away watching
this but you continue the same routine
while you are in bed watching the
youtube videos you don't think that
we are creatures of
behavior
you don't think that this pattern is
gonna
try to come back here
and obviously like there's gonna be
something missing
and your body something inside of you is
gonna feel like no no something's not
right here something's not right so
inevitably you will end up watching
this stuff again so that's where you
have to change
your routine so instead of coming home
and eating and then getting on youtube
why don't you come home and then go for
a walk
and then you eat
and then after you eat
instead of getting on youtube
start reading and then after you're done
reading
then go outside maybe for a nice little
tiny walk or maybe just go and meditate
outside obviously you're hitting your
prayers and all this stuff alhamdulillah
what you should be
uh but you add in like this extra stuff
and you change up the routine now that
you changed up the routine
well there's no
previous behavior that we were following
so now we have a new behavior that we
are implementing therefore
it's more likely that you will stay with
this new routine if you keep up with
this new routine that will allow you
yeah that will allow you to take care of
the um
the urges and the cravings that start
coming your way
and um ultimately at the very end now
again like i said this is gonna look
different for everyone but like the last
thing that i would implement here is
having a specific reason
why you are
cutting it all out while you are
quitting this because if you don't then
it's only a matter of time before the
urges become overwhelming
and you succumb and fall to the urges
and that's facts
double be asked bro really read my
comment above guys so we have the
comments set to like if you if you're a
member if you're a youtube member i put
the link there up in it i get to see
your comments like above everything else
and then i can like address them you're
guaranteed gonna have it addressed
because there's way too many comments
from like you know aside from that so
asa says satan never forces you into sin
you'll manipulate and draw you to it but
it's on you to make that's facts bro um
a test to this is uh any of those times
anyone has a p addiction and
uh you you feel like you're gonna fall
into that and a part of you is like i
don't want to continue
but then you might end up doing it
anyway or you might not continue but
that little brink that's that's that's
free will guys that's free will whether
we want to admit it or not
yeah and people will always start off
like
with strong motivation strong passion to
quit
but then it's like once
one thing
gets difficult when things get hard
that's when
it sets aside the man from the boys
because it shows you like okay how badly
do you want to quit
now that it's like you know you have the
urges and it's all you can think about
and you feel like it's just completely
controlling you like how bad do you want
to quit now do you want to quit it so
bad that you're willing to go through
this urge even
even if you were dying even if like you
were on your knees like crying bleeding
out and everything
like would you still want to quit then
or would you succumb at that point
that's the mentality you got to have
like it's if you want to quit then you
got to be all into the day you die
i want to give a quick shout out to
abdul he is the king of this stream
uh became a youtube member today we got
another youtube member today uh someone
asks maybe someone asked us before
uh i don't know if you're talking about
yourself there uh but will you ever
bring fans out on the live like 10 fans
per stream three minutes each something
like that
fans okay i don't like this whole thing
about fans uh
like it gives this notion that
we are above y'all and i don't like
personally i can't speak on behalf of
the brothers at all there's three
muslims not one guys come on but me
personally i like this notion that i'm a
muslim i'm a human being you guys are
human beings too and i like to keep that
in mind like
okay so basically if you guys see my
website here
i'm doing uh
chats so you can you know before you get
on the program you can do all you can
book a free 30-minute chat yesterday i
had a free 30-minute chat with uh you
know a client from
uh he's from sharjah in the emirates and
he came and we talked for a good like 30
minutes at the end of it he said bro i
thought you know this was going to be
weird and i'm going to feel like a fan
and i'm going to tell you all this and
you're going to act like you know holier
than thou but it was it was very normal
it was very natural subhanallah and i
just really felt like this it was just a
brother talking to a brother
and i was like yo that's how it should
be bro voila like there's too many
people that that like they let things
get to the head and may allah protect us
from that i mean
yeah yeah i mean that's that's what i do
with my coaching as well bro
you keep it you keep it real man because
we ain't nothing special
we're just trying to do our part
and uh that'll that'll be like a
shameless plug for both of us huh
there you go uh
you know how someone asked this question
they're they're youtube members so we
gotta answer it what do you guys think
you guys think we should do that
yeah i think that'd be dope yeah i think
it's a good idea
all right next member question i will
ask do you guys believe abstaining from
movies and tv shows is realistic in this
day and age
100
it's there's two things right so i've
already lived a lifestyle where i
completely stripped away all forms of
entertainment and then i've lived the
lifestyle where all i had was
entertainment
and i found that you know what like
you can do either
but if you're gonna have the
entertainment then there needs to be a
place for it and there needs to be
awareness when you're watching the
entertainment because you don't want to
just watch some you don't want to just
watch anything
you don't just want to consume anything
so you got to be very mindful of what
you are consuming if you're going to
watch a movie if you're going to watch a
tv show
um but even if you didn't like
life is amazing without this stuff
i agree bro couldn't have said it better
um
moderation modesty that's
that's something that dean teaches us
what is modesty modesty is the tendency
to be moderate and to come across as
moderate and how you appear at all this
very important skill because
it's easy to want to flaunt
modesty is difficult
next year's remember abdul salam alaikum
brothers welcome
question about productivity how you guys
organize your schedule and stay
productive or king of productivity going
no bro you were the king intimacy
y'all thought he was the king of
intimacy meaning the king of re
productivity but no you're also
productive
that's a good one
for productivity um
man i'm just gonna you know give the
advice that these brothers gave to me
which i don't know why they're dumping
me king but
uh
i would say start with making a list of
things you want to accomplish
yeah exactly this is probably knows
what's up make a list even if it's just
you know three things
and make sure you accomplish those three
things also you need a clear goal in
mind right so productivity means that
you're you're you know you're working
towards something you're achieving some
kind of goal you're being productive
you're producing good works basically uh
so you know me sitting watching the
squid game 11 times in a row which i
didn't
but just for example
bro
i saw the first episode of my pops
and it looked like
it looked entertaining but it didn't
really like
it wasn't much
it was a wild show but it was very
entertaining but subhanallah like just
the underlying message is just
you walk away with a reduction in your
value that you attribute to a human's
life
and this is something that i took away
yes i took away that
you can be at the top but it basically
showed you that to get to the top you
must leave everyone else behind
i know it's a tv show guys but sabana if
you don't see the propaganda
like protect you from that
i mean i need to finish my example
yeah
yeah but me sitting washing your show a
lot of times is not um
not productive right you have to be
working towards something you have to
have a a goal that you can always go
back to right so if you're working or if
you're studying and you don't want to do
it you have to remember why you're doing
it you have to remember the goal and
that knowledge of why it will carry you
very far inshallah and also remember you
know
a muslim is supposed to strive for
perfection in in everything that he does
or that she does
i would only add
that in order to be really productive
and just start
like don't think about it just
whatever you do like once you have that
list write it the day before
and um
wake up and just go just you do like do
your little routine whatever you do and
then just start i don't think just start
yeah i'm glad you mentioned that because
uh we also have this idea of yakin in
islam certainty and uh
told me there was a study done on people
who had
like 100 conviction that they will do
something versus people with 99
so there's that so you know when you you
guys are like you know oh inshallah i'll
do this you know yeah probably i'll get
to it you'd never end up getting to it
it's because that one percent
uncertainty a little bit it basically
becomes 100 in the end right but if
you're like 100 percent i'm going to do
it then like hollis is getting done so
man that was a really
why does your voice sound so deep all of
a sudden
i
just woke up not too long ago man so i'm
tired
in good book on productivity
and self-improvement hacks check that
out um but aside from that you guys have
any books
i would say
when it comes to these things like it
it's mostly experience like going
through it and then the little things
that people might say here and there but
to spend so much of your time reading
these books
it's kind of like mental masturbation
like
you already know the answer you're just
trying to read it to get something more
to get something extra when it's like
it's not that it's not that complicated
it's very simple just make a list you
know what you got to do just go and do
it that's it
very simple and if you're going to read
like
three better stuff
you know like read the hadees read the
quran read
uh different
i don't know just different things but
you could spend your time better you
know reading things that are better than
how to be more productive
what would you say to this question
and please read it out loud bro for the
the people that are on apple podcast on
spotify and
on with us
disney film have trauma they transmit to
kids think about mufasa dying in lion
king dependence on a gin for worldly
pleasures etc disney is insidious i've
heard a lot about disney like they loki
kind of put like images of like you know
like a penis or something like in the
body of minnie mouse or something like
that and then the writing of the words
and all that stuff and um you know what
i i would honestly fully believe it i
would honestly believe it and i don't i
don't know
to be honest i'm not well versed on this
i'm not going to say about program
trauma or anything like that but i think
it is very likely it's very possible
because when a kid you know sees
something like that you know it might be
traumatizing for some people i never
felt that way about anything watching
cartoons or something die
but uh i i can understand how that would
you all notice after disney bought
marvel marvel's just been
degenerate
[Music]
okay i got i actually got something to
add to that all right so
think of it like this like
you watch this kid this show as a kid
and there there's this plot going on
and there's uh this problem right this
trauma that's occurring whatever it is
like
there's some kind of problem that the
main character has to go through
right
and um
for some reason as a kid you start
seeing this
and then
you get kind of consumed with this idea
that like okay you have to you have to
go through this trauma
and actually
i take i'll take everything just forgot
what i just said because i think i just
like you see something in my head i was
like yo okay never mind
so disregard that
thank you bro
turkish selfies aladdin is a classic
example attacking the hand cutting
within the movie princess jasmine
showing audra while wearing hijab
what do you mean about that man
it's
well you guys come to the uk yes
inshallah in charlotte
i do believe at least for me and angel
from
the limited
uh
conversation that i've been having at
least with him lately maybe rami can
agree with this
umrah is uh
high on the priority list i will say
that
i won't say that it's above
our travels in terms of chronological
order but omra's up there so
it's just getting out this whole uh
situation
you guys want to end the live stream
yeah one day
not the live stream but the live vp
it basically turns the live stream now
yeah
yo guys i mean we still got the message
across
uh
that's a question we've never been asked
before
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
um
the leader of the muslims the leader bro
you had a lot of amazing leaders after
that but
come on you're never gonna have anyone
that can compare it to the prophet
[Music]
well as the salallahu yeah now bro juma
is in uh three hours for me yup it's in
almost
about two hours
this is tough bro
this is tough i agree 100
ace says i hear you on hell i listened
to uh i listened to a lot of tupac back
in the day and i completely embraced
thinking i needed to endure and live a
thug life
not a righteous one
it's not just park but that's the whole
hip-hop industry too like
hey listen it shows
that we are a product of our environment
your environment doesn't just have to be
the people that you hang out with it
could be the music that you're listening
to all the time it could be the movies
that you're watching that is your
environment because again like you got
to think about it what are we
what are we we are
we are the spirit
inside this body which is like a vessel
that's allowing us to
uh be in this dunya experiences dunya
but this vessel will inevitably
come to its end and our
will go on to the day of judgment in
front of our creator
right so
if we are the spirit we are always
observing we're always observing
everything right now even though i'm
speaking i'm still observing at the same
time you guys are listening you guys are
observing
all right so if you are spending time
outside with friends or at school or in
some mall or something like that you are
observing
everything
all right and
if you are listening to music or
watching a tv show it is no different
you are still observing said
so
it goes to show that we are a product of
our environment and a lot of people you
know on the side don't ask me why i
have mannerisms
like an african-american why do i speak
like african-americans because i grew up
around african-americans so that was my
environment i'm a product of my
environment
it would be no different if i grew up
around
a uh
a group of very
tradition or gays or traditional white
people
uh caucasians
you know the very proper caucasian
people nothing against them but if i
grew up around them then my mannerisms
in the way that i speak would definitely
reflect that and you wouldn't be downing
hot sauce with every meal bro that's for
sure
i don't know boy then white people love
the hot sauce
right real quick how do i get muscle
caloric surplus progressive overload
you wanted a quick answer
the music industry deserves a separate
episode i feel like it's
worse oof
um i think we should cut it off there
you wanna do five more minutes bro sure
but i think
only because
just became a member so
if he or she has a question why not man
for those i remember you from last week
welcome to the cult
lyrics replace your conscious
that's true
like y'all have listened to a song in
the past
and like you're repeating the lyrics in
your head and it's like it's kind of
like feeding your ego
and like the brother said he was
listening to tupac and he felt like you
know living the thug life was like
that's what he had to do and it was like
bro like i used to listen to so many
songs like that and one of them used to
be drake and like drake used to say a
lot so i'll repeat it and then sometimes
i would be like why am i saying this or
like
lil wayne or young jeezy
i don't know like it just
stuck for a lot
is this pre-recorded yeah bro it's
pre-recorded this is not a live stream
i know you're looking for bro how many
times do i have to say like no more you
know nikai proposals or even inquiries
but on
online i am looking for a wife
everybody listens to threepack
three-part sunda
yo
that's why they say that the uh
the quran and music can't exist in the
same heart
okay okay okay guys wrap up last final
questions and then uh we will end off
this
episode
yeah and for everyone watching just know
that it's um
rummy before you answer that
things are only gonna get better
in terms of our lives
because we we plan on doing the live eps
and even though this one kind of turned
to like a live
q a towards the very end i don't know
why
um
and know that
the way that we do videos is the way
that we've done videos in the past where
they were pre-recorded
when it's just us three we want to do
these videos but instead of
pre-recording we're gonna throw it in
live
and really stick to these
topics and like go into these videos as
if we were pre-recording it it's just
that we will open up the comment section
to those that are members that we are
not being bombarded by so many questions
that we completely veer off track like
we did in this video
so that's essentially it from next week
on
remember if you're not a member
become a member because things are about
to get real spicy over here
we about to bring the tabasco that's
sriracha
actually it's called shatter
it's like oh yeah i gotta be ready
all right then uh golden calf agrees to
what you're saying keeping them is a
topic
uh relevant questions only obviously for
members flow is open to you
uh for real though love your streams
enjoyed a lot who's your next guest
we'll rewind the video we talked about
the next guest coming up inshaallah
all right so
with that being said
end
go get some sleep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i had to go i had to pin them
come on bro
i swear just about to leave but i had a
feeling so i stayed
what do i do for fun
listen
primarily i do martial arts for fun
um
anything physical anything like exercise
related it could be rock climbing you
could be ninja warrior training
um it could just be going for walker
stuff
every now and then i might play a video
game
or i might watch anime but again
mindfully
mindfully consume these things for a
purpose for a reason
that's it my phone's about to die so
with that being said assalamu alaykum
uh we treat our youtube members here
with love just like family just like
they're proud of their teeth and family
you know
today
this will be the last question that we
answered today because you know for
those we can't remember so we got to
honor that
i have a question what do you think
about parents sending their children
from muslim to anonymous countries uh
more specificity or more specifically
when it comes to sending their girls to
live alone rami thoughts
well i mean it really depends on the
situation and i'm going to be completely
frank if you're sending a guy
it's it's not haram if you're sending a
woman by herself it may very well be
haram because a woman is not supposed to
travel by herself let alone be in a cafe
country by herself you know the
amount of of
um
suffering that she could go through
potentially may allah protect her and
all the women allah i mean it's you know
it's there
um
whereas you know for a man
like no one
no one really cares to like assault a
man sexually or harass him at you know
it's like men are like they're not
valued they're not looking in that way
so it is you know haram for a woman to
to to go off on her own like that uh but
i would say it really depends you know
some of these countries are wor torn
some of these countries sometimes they
come just get an education and go back
home because the education here is you
know valued more back home and they'll
make a lot more so it really depends on
the situation as possible um but i would
say
primarily for men
a lot of fitness that can come up about
from that so you know have to be very
very careful
it might be better
all right
until next week man assalamu alaikum
foreign